so
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to week six everyone in a happy
nfl sunday that's right you just tapped
into the br betting squad ride live in
the bleacher report app presented by
draftkings my name is connor rogers
alongside the man and people as always
you want to get on his good side that is
greg ivory greg give me a hoodie count
today how many give him away
uh just take the over just take the over
and in fact i'm giving away one right
now shout out to
b-a-w-w-e-t says kareem hunt two
touchdowns plus 450.
i like that i like that one but funny i
like that a lot bringing it early on
friday we asked you on social and the
app to drop your locks of who's scoring
a touchdown as we always do here are the
most popular picks that he sent us no
surprise king henry at the top travis
kelsey right behind him those two
basically live up on this board cooper
cup ezekiel elliott austin eckler lamar
jackson with the rushing touchdowns we
know what he did last week the mvp
performance from the mvp aaron jones
dj moore pretty loaded board here really
exciting week ahead to get things going
though let's take a look back at last
week of some of our favorite lock legend
videos that you sent us that didn't make
the show
i gotta figure out anytime touchdown
look at the clock hey jake what's wrong
today got anytime touchdown picks right
here and the stingray picker doing a
little walk ball one-on-one we're gonna
get to choose their touchdown score al
mozart gary terry hours terry mclaren
devonte adams anytime score
justin jefferson it is lock it in got a
bagel what the
why is that in my bagel
all right greg tell the people what are
we giving away today
i'm not only giving out hoodies
everybody i'm not only giving out
hoodies i'm also giving away two not one
but two
nfl jersey gift cards one goes to the
winning lock legend and the other goes
to a lucky commenter
like you so get in the comments and do
what you do if you need a jersey if you
need a hoodie i need gifts i need emojis
but most importantly connor most
importantly i need winners only please
fill those comments up because that's
what i need i need winners that's what
i'm looking for all right as always we
have four legendary picks to show you
looking for those winners only the last
one standing will be our week six squad
rod leader and they get the boost from
draftkings so let's get right into it
our first pitch comes from a familiar
face in w tramwell tell us who's scoring
a touchdown today
vr nation we got the anytime touchdown
plinko board let's see what we get
aaron jones lock it in
all right aaron jones coming in at that
plus money pretty nice we got our first
decision of the day
on tap here's our second pitch from p
18.
got ezekiel elliott anytime touchdown
score lock it in
reeling in locks i like it you heard
from our first two legends greg who are
you riding with here the flanko legend
or the fishing legend
first connor first i gotta talk to the
people most importantly get into the
comments and tell me we should ride with
the plinko legend or the fishing legend
uh connor
the plinko legend
both videos was impressive both videos
was impressive both videos took
creativity
but i see aaron jones over there plus
money and i know what we can do here to
add to that
and uh aaron jones he hasn't scored the
last couple weeks but
he's due he is due we know that they
like to run the ball in green bay to go
along with aaron rodgers so uh that's a
little enticing to me that's a little
enticing to me connor what about you i'm
with you i love the plus money let's
juice it up even a bit more and you
nailed it aaron jones looking for the
end zone trying to find his way back in
there it just means he's due it's not a
drought so i'm excited about aaron jones
here of course zeke has kind of been old
reliable for the last couple of years
there's no doubt about that but i like
the odds better on the aaron jones side
all right greg let's let the people pick
this one what do you say for round one
yes sir conor i am in the comments
and today i have the cousin of the handy
dandy ipad i have the handy dandy phone
for the people that are new to the show
this is the handy dandy phone this is
how you get your hoodies and this is how
you get your jerseys and i'm in here
connor and i see
sea bird sea bird says plinko legend or
shirt plinko legend for sure shout out
to uc burke you are walking away with
the hoodie connor the the comments are
jumping i see chris
amiano says zeke to the end zone zeke to
the end zone they're back and forth next
one i choose we're just gonna rock with
it coming we're just gonna rock with it
uh
i see
raider 909 raider 909 says aaron jones
with the aaron rodgers emoji there it is
uh
not emoji but a gif uh so it appears
conor it appears
the plinko legend
aaron jones and our boy w trammell is
moving on to the next round that's right
w trammell moving on to round two but we
still have two challengers remaining
that he has to get by let's move things
over to round two and our next pitch
comes from kyle grimes 22. kyle let's
see what you got in store for us for
week six
all right anytime touchdown this week
here are our choices cop scary terry
james robinson dj moore austin eckler
i'm gonna throw him up
catch him in the book
see what we got for this week
here we go
cooper cup
the one take wonder the magic legend you
heard from them greg who you riding with
here the fishing let the we got the
plinko we got the magic legend cooper
cup aaron jones man what are you
thinking here
it sounds tough this one's tough connor
i'm not gonna lie but that's why we got
the people that's why i talk to him and
that's why i'm gonna tell them get into
the comments and tell me who we should
ride with come on guys tell us if we
should go with the plinko legend and
aaron jones or if we should go with the
magic legend and cooper cup uh
i'll be honest conor i wasn't impressed
by the magic i was not impressed by the
magic in this video but i am impressed
by the pick cooper cup has been balling
this year and he's taking on that new
york giant secondary uh matthew stafford
just loves to find him he just loves the
final but connor
that plus money over there it's just
it's just singing to me it's singing to
me what about you well how about this
greg how about we get cooper cup to b
plus money i think that should be our
objective here the man has been targeted
56 times in five games for five
touchdowns they just throw this guy the
ball
non-stop so if we can get this to plus
money i love the cooper cup pick against
the giants team that has had a tough
year they're banged up and defense just
hasn't been as good as it was last year
not much of a pass rush so
i don't really get to decide i'm trying
to sway the people towards cooper cup
trying to persuade this comment section
let's let the people decide round
two connor you made a great point i mean
we
here on the squad ride show can only
boost this up i mean we can only do it
here and uh if we could boost cooper cup
up to some plus money why not so let me
get into these comments so let me see
what these people are saying uh
i got i got jman321 saying cup is a lot
and is amazing this year
that book thing was
fire uh shout out to you j man 321 you
were walking away with the hoodie uh bad
sports takes uh oh look out here black
sports tech says i think aaron jones all
the way he's gonna pop up
i mean i also thinks that two best works
safe that wasn't such a bad sports
thanks shout out to you you were walking
away with a hoodie uh connor i got one
more one more emmy i see uh
i see
wd-13
wd13 says cooper cup
rocket with you connor wd13 you are also
walking away with a hoodie
but it appears connor it appears i
called it
the magic legend
kyle grimes s22
and cooper cup is moving on to the next
round man love the cooper cup pick let's
hope it can uh survive this final round
kyle grimes moving on to the final round
going for title squad ride leader going
for that nfl
jersey all right winner of this round
takes all you know the deal by now four
four last round here next up is l2
32. let's see his pick
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the witch legend going with austin
eckler i am officially terrified for all
of us but love the creativity based
around halloween which is rapidly
approaching
all right greg we got the final round
here you got to ride with somebody to
finish this thing off austin eckler and
the witch legend with a magic legend
with our boy cooper cub
connor i'm over here trying to catch my
breath or i don't know i'm i was spooky
a little spooky no halloween is around
the corner uh but let me talk to the
people let me talk to the people get in
the comments and tell me who we should
ride with should we ride with the witch
legend and austin eckler or should we
ride with cooper cup
my voice connor's pick i mean he does
like it he did try to convince everybody
to rock with it cooper cup the magic
legend uh
i don't know connor i i don't i do know
austin ecker has been balling this year
i do know austin eckley's been balling
this year but he's facing
baltimore that baltimore defense in
baltimore you know they they turn up in
baltimore uh so i i i don't know if i
wanna lean that way i think i'm gonna
rock with you in cooper cup bro like
what's your take are you still leaning
cooper cup or are you
gonna tap in with austin eggplant no i'm
still going cooper cub i'm a little
biased i'm facing eckler and fantasy
this week i want nothing to do with him
getting in the end zone and i don't know
about the whole witch thing he might be
under a spell right now let's go with
cooper cup instead but i don't get to
decide the final i i spoke
my convincing argument for the people
greg
are they listening are they with us for
cooper cup as our booster yeah
yeah i literally that's all i see connor
that's all i see is cooper cup in the
comments right now coop coop coop i got
d-b-r-u-n-a-c-h-e
coop coop shout out to you you're
walking away with the hoodie uh i got
uh-oh
seaburg c burke is backseat a bolinger a
bowling girl is rocking with a bolinger
333 is rocking with eckler in fact a
rocket with echo uh hold on
i see i see more cooper cup love
i see more cooper cut hold on hold on
all right here we go here we go
max rexella max rexel is calling it max
rexella is calling he says
cooper cup for the win cooper cup for
the win so shout out to the magic legend
shout out to cooper cup and shout out to
kyle grimes 22.
we are rocking with cooper cup uh connor
we're rocking with cooper cup that's the
squad ride let's go get a touchdown let
me show you guys some magic though let's
pull up the graphics so i can show you
guys some magic you guys see cooper cup
-140 let me show you something that us
here only on squat ride can do there it
is there it is that's the magic plus 100
uh thanks to our friends at draftkings
they boosted that from 140 to plus 100
for us check b our betting social for a
link to the odds we'll send us your
screenshots of your bets
send us your videos and your
celebrations
but we want winners
and winners only please don't forget
that we got it to plus money greg we got
it to plus money winners only please
cooper cup hopefully going to be a
winner for everybody watching this show
that taps in and rides with the squad
we're not done yet got more locks greg's
got more hoodies and one more jersey to
give away so it's not just going to be
kyle grimes walking away with that nfl
jersey hanging out in the br betting
community stream you already know the
deal we asked you this week who you'd
bet a hundred dollars on to score
multiple touchdowns in week six this is
what we love to do we're looking for
those big time mods we picked two of our
favorite comments and want to know what
you think greg let's get into it
yeah what i need you guys to do is get
in the comments and tell me which of
these is the better take i'm giving away
a hoodie so whoever you choose let's
take a look at the first comment from
the sports blogger
sports blogger says lamar jackson
grabbing two rushing touchdowns i do not
dislike this one this one is very very
very doable uh connor
what's your take
i love it he's already done it once this
year right he did it against the chiefs
uh in week two in a win right we know in
games that are shootouts which
this game is going to be when you look
at who they're playing across the way
with justin herbert and he had to do
this against patrick mahomes lamar puts
the team on his back he does not have a
great offense around him mostly because
of injuries and when that happens lamar
will look to run and get into the end
zone so the odds here are good it's a
bold bet there's no doubt about that i
think i'm riding with them greg what
else we got in store
i i like this one a lot i'm not even
gonna lie uh but the next comment the
next commenter comes from z mcdowell 88
z mcdowell 88
and he says
henry is always
a good bet to score two touchdowns i
think zeke is going to have two himself
but it might be one rushing and one
receiving like last week
zeke yeah he did have a good week last
week connor do you like this take do you
think zeke is getting back into the end
zone for two touchdowns i don't think
it's crazy he's done it every single
week besides week one i'm pretty sure at
this point when you factor in the
receiving threat as well
in an offense that's just so loaded my
only question here greg and why i might
lean lamar besides how promising the
odds are as well
is that this is a dallas offense that
they're going to spread the ball around
they have a pretty tough opponent i know
new england's been disappointing but we
know what amari's done we know what cd's
done they even got the tight ends going
dak can run in the red zone when he
needs to i just wonder are we finally
due for a week where zeke kind of takes
a step back and catches his breath a
little bit what do you think
yeah they do have a lot of options out
there in dallas and you have a great
point you have a great point with a lot
of options you know that may limit zeke
chances of scoring two he might get in
there one but two
i don't know i do like the lamar take
though cause that team is uh
when he goes they go so i like that take
uh let me hop into this the comments so
let me hop into the comments because i
have to see
who the people says that we should ride
with uh
i'm in the comments and i see
uh somebody's still talking about cooper
cup ball is live shout out to you i mean
cooper cup is the squad ride and that's
who are we are walking uh running
with today uh maxwell rexella is back
into the comments maxwell rex goes back
into the comments he's he's saying lamar
jackson lamar jackson uh shout out to
you
um
joe yan is in the comments as well joe
han is also in the comments and he is
also he's also saying lamar eat baby
lamar so hey
it's apparent the peop the people have
spoken the people have spoken uh
i'm just gonna give it to the box the
sports blogger give it to the sports
blogger he's the winner of the comic
contest the sports blogger is getting
a hoodie
love the comments this week now it's our
turn to get involved give our crazy
takes it's boldest bets time you know
what it is
we've had a lot of fun with this some
weeks we get a little crazy some weeks
we scale back i think this week we're
gonna throw those big time darts again
greg tell the people what we need from
them before we close this thing out
all right all right get in the comments
and tell me whether you're riding with
me are you riding with my boy connor my
boy connor has hit a couple of these
he does hit a couple of these so connor
tell the people what do you got this
week i'm excited about this one after
cooling off last week i feel like i got
to come back i'm going jamar chase not
one but two touchdowns against the lions
there was a lot of talk pre-draft of if
the bengals should take chase or instead
they should go offensive line and take
penne sewell i think chase has nothing
to prove he's been unguardable this year
he's not a guy that needs bulletin board
material but he's gonna bring it anyway
this week i think he gets in the end
zone not once but twice against a weak
lions defense and plus 600 greg let's
make some money today what are you
thinking
yeah hey i'm rooting i'm rooting for you
he's on my fantasy team so i need those
two tubs baby need those two tubs but i
want to take it to the mvp race connor i
want to take it to the mvp race lamar
jackson
justin herbert they're playing they're
playing each other
uh
but i want them to combine for over 600
passing yards you guys go out there
combined for over 600 passing yards i
mean you just mentioned this one might
be a high scoring game so you guys go
out there and throw that thing around
for a little bit give me that plus 380
draftking already boosted it for us so
uh go sling the rock a little bit guys
and uh let's make some money
i like that call it's gonna be a
shootout you can get you know we've seen
herbert have no problem doing this if
you can get 330 out of herbert 270 out
of lamar we know lamar uses legs as well
that's an exciting one the odds are huge
let's have some fun let's make some
money but we need to know who are the
people riding with they going jamar
chase two touchdowns and me they're
going with you with the lamar jackson
herbert special and i think you still
have one more nfl jersey to give away
yes sir
i'm going to give away the jersey first
connor i'm going to give away the jersey
first and guess what i'm giving away
to red sox in five red stocks and five
says
jamar chase is a lock let's talk
red spots
you are walking away with the jersey
your choice now
i'm giving away hoodies connor i am in
the commons giving away hoodie i got
jj snail jj snail uh he said greg's
picks at plus 380 that's fire shouts out
to you appreciate you brother uh you
were walking away with a hoodie i got
ball is life ball is life is back i
think they got a hoodie earlier but you
know we show love to people that show
love to us they said
they said cooper cup they're they're
giving us rides for our squad ride yeah
they're giving us goodbye
i already gave you a hoodie but if i
yeah
yeah hoodie hoodie hoodie give them
money i got one more one more
uh landon landon foss 18 landon foss 18
says uh
rocking with both of our picks there
that's what both of our picks the
basketball shout outs
shout out to landon you were walking
away with eddie connor
let's take this thing on home man let's
take a stay on home craig i'm feeling
oddly optimistic that this is the week
all the long shots hit all the the
comment contests the boldest bets good
luck with your wagers everyone congrats
all our hoodie and jersey winners br
betting will dm you within 24 hours so
have no fear that stuff is getting your
way thanks everyone that commented you
got a comment if you want to win and you
guys have been bringing it every single
week
greg's been those comments have been
flying so we've been having fun with
that are legends the lock legends w
trammell p mcquade 18 kyle grimes 22 of
course l2 32. enjoy your nfl sunday drop
your real time whoa whoa whoa whoa hey
connor before before we get out of here
i have to give out more hoodies i got
rich bark tails rich martel says higgy
he's on my fantasy team so rich bartels
you are walking away with the hoodie
that's probably a lot of plus money uh
here we go
mike steve ritter is in the comments
mike steve fritters in the comments and
he's rocking with your pick jamar chase
jamar chase uh shout out to mike steve
ritter um
ah that that that's it connor that's it
all right we're done here alongside greg
ivory my name is connor rogers see you
next week same time same place
[Music]
you